what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Dr Doom and this comic is
amazing
normally I would do all of volume 2 at
once but this comic's so good I just got
to cover it by itself uh so a few things
to understand for those of you guys who
are just joining us you'll find a link
to volume one down in the description so
you can watch that you can get caught up
with everything but the long and short
of this here is that there was an
experiment that was conducted on the
moon that resulted in the formation of a
black hole and at the time that the I
guess experiment initially took place a
whole bunch of nuclear missiles were
launched from latviria now it wasn't
Doctor Doom who did it instead it was
people who were trying to discredit
Doctor Doom and specifically trying to
conquer latviria so more or less a coup
but the result is that Doctor Doom has
basically been on the run ever since
Kane the Conqueror has been popping out
popping in and out really over the
course of the whole first volume and so
where this picks up is actually the
first time they've spent any meaningful
time together over the course of the
story arc now Doctor Doom and Kang have
a history a pretty lengthy history and
in fact back in the day and the original
comic escapes me but back in the day in
Marvel there was a point when came to
conquer after he adopted the identity of
ramatut and was defeated by The
Fantastic Four in ancient Egypt he ended
up coming back to the modern era and
then after meeting Dr Doom basically
fashioned a suit of his own that was
similar to Dr Doom and started calling
himself the Scarlet Centurion right so
just one of those little bits of History
here but the long and short of it is
that these guys have a lot of respect
for each other but their egos are off
the charts right they're like they're
like Dwayne Johnson cooking the books
with Black Adam the hierarchy of power
in the DC Universe is about to change
right I mean like it's just a whole new
level of ego like that's literally what
this is and so that's why one of the
first things they talk about here is
whether or not they're actually related
and that's one of the things that's just
kind of a big question that's existed in
Marvel Comics for eons and eons and the
reason why is because Kane the
conqueror's real name is Nathaniel
Richards and of course you have Reed
Richards and Reed Richard's father's
name is Nathaniel Richards so for years
and years and Marvel Comics and I mean
when I say years I mean like decades
right for like the last 50 years or so
in Marvel Comics give or take a little
bit fans always found themselves asking
the question is Kane the conquer
Nathaniel Richards is he descended from
Doctor Doom as he descended from Reed
Richards and in fact they're going to
pose this question as to whether or not
Nathaniel Richards right came the
Conqueror is actually the father of Reed
from like maybe a different universe or
operating under a different change in
this character's history or whatever the
case happens to be we'll talk about that
here in a second because it gets a
little wonky but one of the things that
happens here is that these guys are
basically taking the long road right
instead of just like teleporting
somewhere or having some vessel from
latviria pick them up and take them
where they need to be or cane the
Conqueror using technology instead they
literally have to lay low so they're
going old school man they're hitching
rides and like train cars and like
walking and stuff it's cool
unfortunately for a couple of these poor
sets these guys basically decide to stow
away on one of the trains literally
hitch a ride and then like one of them
gets into the train car with Doctor Doom
and Kang and is like hey what's going on
gentlemen do you guys mind sharing this
train car with me now is anybody who
knows anything about Doctor Doom knows
this guy does not suffer vagrants
so they blast him out of the train car
and send that guy flying to his Doom
right after that it picks up with the
two of them just kind of there at like a
campfire right and again that's kind of
how this conversation continues on that
what ends up happening is Dr Doom even
goes as far as to say I've heard rumors
that you're read Richard's father and
the response of of King is I've heard
that too but he looks nothing like me
now the reason why this is being thrown
out here is because this goes back to
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four which
we need to continue because if anything
after the the after where we stopped
it's just a handful of like small
ancillary stories right just like one
shots and little mini series and this
Jonathan Hickman just kind of cleaning
things up so it's not Essential by any
standard of measurement but it would be
fun to go back right because we still
have Franklin Richards from the future
who's currently in the present day doing
his thing in Crazy levels of reality
warping and so on and so forth plus
there's the ultimate fate of Ben Grimm
which is kind of screwed up but the
thing about this is that when Jonathan
Hickman wrote The Fantastic Four and
specifically when we got what was called
the big hunt so all these different
variants of Nathaniel Richards Reed's
father across the Multiverse all facing
off against each other and jumping in
and out of different universes right Age
of Ultron Days of Future Past different
things like that that one of the big
theories that Rose to prominence during
that time is that because Reed Richard's
father's name is Nathaniel Richards you
had the great hunt you have variants of
Nathaniel that they all end up becoming
basically versions of Kang and so that's
where that theory came from initially or
really gained the most traction I should
say is that Kang is potentially the
father of Reed so again it's one of
these really interesting things because
when you're talking about a guy like
Kang who does time travel while he has a
lot has had a lot of identities over the
years the reality of this is that Kang
has actually forgotten a lot of the
things that he's done over the course of
his existence right a really good
example of this if you want to put this
to the test tell me what was on the wall
on the left hand side and your third
grade class what did your teacher have
written on the wall what was the name of
your third grade teacher and that's what
you're talking about here right came the
Conqueror jumps in and out of different
points in time all the time right and so
because of that it all just kind of
turns into an amorphous blob of things
he's done but that's why you'll have
comics where somebody will say well King
what about the time that you did this
and he won't know what they're talking
about because he will have forgotten it
and so again it's just one of those
interesting things when it comes to his
character's history so that's why the
theory still holds traction and that's
why it's entirely true but of course
following this it's also Kang basically
telling Doom I'm not I'm not your father
and the response to Doom is I know
you're not perhaps I'm your father right
like it's one of the things where they
kind of go back and forth we never get
any definitive answers truth to tell I
don't think Marvel will ever give us a
definitive answer as to whether or not
Kang is related to Reed Richards or to
Dr Doom which one he's descended from
because it's just one of those cool
little Mysteries that just kind of
exists out there now of course following
this you have uh you have another poor
bastard that decides to roll up on Kane
the Conqueror and Doctor Doom as they're
walking down this uh deserted Highway
these two folks ride up on him right and
one of them's like so what do we got
here right I ain't never seen more
colorific looking chuckle ducks in all
my life what's your name fancy Cleopatra
referring to Kane the Conqueror and
they're like how about you Steely Dan
what's behind your iron curtain and of
course Dr Doom and respect bonds to this
helps them finish with all their living
anybody who is aware of their doom and
even
act like that right this is
you will be made to meet your maker and
that's literally it but one of the
coolest things about this this is one of
the reasons why I love this comic so
much one of the coolest things about
this is that again there's a lot of
respect between the two depending on the
story arc they're mortal enemies but the
reality here is that the intelligence of
Doctor Doom can never be underestimated
by anybody even read Richards and people
like Valeria Richards the daughter of
Reed who's every bit as smart as Doctor
Doom and Reed himself people like Moon
girl who's that intelligent or even Adam
Brashear who's as intelligent right at
least that's what this story solidified
they all basically go to Doctor Doom in
some capacity as the guy that can answer
questions that they have that they
simply can't find answers to on their
own he's wildly intelligent and that's
one of the reasons that his character
even alongside Kang is so cool because
even Kang himself recognizes the
intelligence of Doctor Doom and the
reason why that needs to be respected
but Dr Doom also respects Kang because
between the two of them they have an
unwillingness to be defeated to defy all
the odds and to ensure they come out on
top more so than that what Doctor Doom
respects Above All Is One a person's
intelligence and a person's fortitude
how hard are you willing to work to get
what you want do you take the easy Road
or do you take the Hard Road even if the
Hard Road doesn't need to be taken do
you take it anyway for no other reason
than the fact that it'll make you more
well-rounded and make you better and
Kane the Conqueror is very much the guy
who will take the hard road everything
he has he worked for with the exception
of the time travel device he stole that
I mean truth to tell let's be honest
with ourselves right it was literally
doctor Doom's time platform in the 30th
century and Kane just took it right but
outside of that outside of that
the guy the guy is unwilling to give
ground and will always do whatever it
takes to win and doom can always respect
that and so that's why you have this
this kind of conversation where do match
the question why are you even bothering
to help me and the response of of King
is I explained I will conquer the world
that you save and the response to Doom
is I will save no world and again King
says no I've seen the Utopia that you've
created and then the response to Doom is
you've also seen a future where Earth is
overrun by a cohort of mechanized
dinosaurs and that's when Kang makes
this amazing point and he says true
still wherever Dr Doom stands there
exists a lust for power one I can use to
my advantage and that's where Doom calls
us Bluff and he says honestly I think
you're just lonely and the two of them
just kind of start going back and forth
I am not you're lonely no you're lonely
I'm not lonely because I'm Dr Doom and
I'm a misanthrope well I'm more of a
missing I'm a misanthrope times two
right it's literally just kind of this
bickering back and forth and this sort
of nonsensical and almost sort of a
bromance that exists between these guys
I don't know if anybody uses that word
anymore but it's great to see doom and
Kang relating to each other in this way
because more often than not you see them
as enemies it's cool because literally
after they they share this laugh
together the response of Doom is I will
destroy you king and the response of
King is I'll destroy you first Victor
right so it's just one of those cool
little moments that goes on there now
having said that once they make their
way to Texas what ends up going on here
is Doctor Doom has what he calls an ace
in a hole in the sense that he was able
to kind of contact people through kind
of underground Network and say like I
need something delivered to me at this
location so at this point they're
literally just biding time and waiting
when out of nowhere they're met by the
arrival of Paladin with a minigun who
literally just starts spraying the whole
place down literally this guy's just
standing there with a minigun unloading
everything honestly it looks like an M60
but he's just spraying everything down
only for them to find out the way in
which they were found was because of the
orb now here's a few things to explain
here is Paladin an important character
no Paladin sucks he's always sucks he's
never been a relevant guy there's never
been an instance in the history of
Marvel Comics when all these villains
are all teaming up to face off against
the heroes and they're losing and then
Paladin shows up and the day's safe
that's never happened right the guy's
about as irrelevant of a mercenary as
anybody possibly can be but more so than
that the orb this guy's just downright
goofy but it is still cool to see that
they have their history intact so here's
the thing when it comes to the orb this
guy was completely and totally
Irrelevant in Marvel Comics until a
story was written that was called
Original Sin and what this guy had done
is he had discovered the dead body of
The Watcher which had actually been
killed by Nick Fury but he had taken one
of the Watchers eyes and because
everything The Watcher has seen over the
course of his existence was stored
inside of his eyes the orb basically
broadcast all that information to the
world so everybody learned everything
about themselves that they had
previously never known a really good
example of this is during oh my God John
and Hickman's Avengers The New Avengers
when Captain America was originally part
of the Illuminati during the incursions
when like the Multiverse was collapsing
and the Illuminati were talking about
destroying alternate Earth that when he
disagreed his mind was white by Doctor
Strange at the direction of Iron Man and
then he was thrown out of the Illuminati
so he didn't know any of that stuff but
during original sin all those memories
were restored to him and then he had
lost his super soldier serum and just
became this crotchety old son of a gun
and was literally going like like going
after the Illuminati like he took over
shield and brought like the full might
of the US Military and the intelligence
community on to like find the Illuminati
it was amazing man because for a Time
Captain America was kind of a warlord
and it was pretty boss like it was
amazing it's one of the best moments in
the history of Marvel Comics but again
the orb still has one of the Watchers
eyes Now The Watcher himself is back
right but the orb still has one of his
eyes meaning the orb sees all like it
literally has like what you could argue
to be Cosmic awareness although there's
nothing to indicate that it operates on
a universal level but literally like
with the hunt for Doom it's Dooms over
there in Texas right he knows right off
the bat and so what ends up happening is
King brandishes really one of his older
weapons which is called the ultra diode
but what it does is it basically just
saps people love their willpower so it
reduces you down to the most pathetic
version of yourself right so most people
on Twitter and Reddit and the result of
this is that these guys just kind of
cower into like a fetal position and
just sort of cry about how like the end
is nigh their lives don't serve any
useful purpose or anything like that but
the cool thing here is that once the
this plane right this contact lands and
Dr Doom is given his Ace in the Hole
that what we end up finding out is that
is actually the ultimate nullifier now
here's the thing man and I'm kind of
amazed that Christopher cantwell's just
sort of treating this as a thing right
like it's just sort of there the
ultimate nullifier is quite literally
the Ultimate Weapon in Marvel right I
mean I would argue this thing is Way
Beyond The Power of an Infinity Gauntlet
because the thing about the ultimate
nullifier is that the power that it
possesses it's relative to the person
who's using it initially it was created
by Galactus and then it was attained by
the Fantastic Four during the original
Galactus Trilogy literally Johnny Storm
and The Watcher go to galactus's ship
tattoo they steal it they bring it back
to Earth they give it to read and then
Reed starts brandishing this thing and
galactus's face and then Galactus just
flees for his life that's a very
simplified version of what happens but
like this thing scares the hell out of
Galactus and the reason why is because
if you put the ultimate nullifier in the
hands of an idiot it may not necessarily
work you put this thing in the hand of
Reed Richards you could annihilate the
universe Doctor Doom you could Wipe Out
the whole universe the benefit of the
ultimate nullifier is that it doesn't
just destroy whatever you aim it at it
basically makes it so it never existed
so really good example of this is that
if Doctor Doom were to point the
ultimate nullifier at Spider-Man then
Spider-Man would simply cease to exist
not only that it would be as if he never
existed so seemingly nobody would have
ever heard of Spider-Man nobody would
have ever liked any images of Spider-Man
that exists would ultimately be gone
right they would just disappear like
this guy the entire evidence of this
guy's existence would vanish forever
that's really the major implication of
the ultimate nullifier and there's
really no way to bring them back so
that's why I say I mean presumably you
could point this thing at like The
Infinity Gauntlet or any Cosmic entities
probably even the Living Tribunal maybe
I'm not really sure I guess it just kind
of depends but the thing is insanely
powerful so the fact that is in the
possession of Doctor Doom means this guy
means businessman and so what ends up
happening is that once he has the
ultimate nullifier we end up finding out
this is the reason why King was here in
the first place now the reality here is
that Kang wanted to attain the nullifier
for himself but unless he decided to
screw up the time stream Doctor Doom had
to get his hands on it in order for Kang
to take it from Doctor Doom things have
to happen in a certain order when it
comes to the progression of time
throughout the Universe and so as soon
as Dr Doom gets the ultimate nullifier
king turns on him and then steals the
ultimate nullifier but before he can get
away this is the crazy thing before he
can get away Doctor Doom quite literally
stabs Kane the Conqueror in the neck
like literally stabs him in the neck
right blood goes everywhere leaves him
for dead and then just takes off on his
horse right just like rides off on his
horse and so following that Dr Doom
basically ends up getting to Mexico and
when he arrives there which is kind of
weird to see he ends up basically
grabbing a payphone and he calls Reed
Richards from a payphone and the reason
why is because during the time when doom
and Kang were traveling together the
question that they had is how do we do
how do we end that black hole and they
were asking questions like can we use
antimatter it's like well antimatter is
still composed of masks so literally
Mass plus Mass equals more mass so if
you fire some kind of antimatter cannon
at a black hole all it's going to do is
just absorb all that mass and grow
bigger you're not going to do anything
but feed it and so that's where Doom's
mind began to sort of look over the
entirety of the situation that's when he
calls up Reed Richards and he says your
black hole solution is simple read my
guess is that it's standing right next
to you and he says Brashear the blue
Marvel send him inside the antleon
experiment now the initial response of
Reed is in antimatter Collision will
just create more mass and the response
to Doctor Doom is listen you idiot right
he says send him past the Event Horizon
he can generate a massive amount of
negative energy to dissipate the black
hole I know he survived the nuclear
explosion so there's a chance The
Singularity will not incinerate him and
then he ultimately leaves now here's the
reason why that would work remember Adam
Brashear is an anti-matter reactor right
he literally he's basically a guy that
draws all of his power from the
antimatter universe so imagine you're
not like Superman dross's power from the
sun right solar energy gives him all of
his abilities like it feeds his
abilities that's what happens with Adam
Adam Brashear instead of him being fed
by the power of the sun he's fed by a
whole different universe first but it's
also why his power is seemingly
Limitless because so long as the
Negative Zone exists he'll be powerful
and he could presumably Channel all the
power of the Negative Zone in different
forms and Fashions it's why when it
comes down to like physical strength
Adam Brashear is arguably the single
strongest character in the Marvel
Universe the best way to test that and I
hope Marvel gives it to us one day I
want to see blue Marvel versus like
World breaker Hulk I want to see that
fight because that would be dope but
literally because he's an antimatter
reactor that's the response of Doctor
Doom I'm not a physicist so I don't
really even know how all this works but
as I understand it it would basically be
two objects hitting and just canceling
each other out right negative one plus
positive one equals zero that's really
what this would be so I'm kind of
curious to see exactly how this would
play out but that's where the story ends
let me know if you guys want me to cover
the rest of this because again Doctor
Doom is amazing thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace